all right a few other unhinged reactions
to cocaine found at the White House of
course in an area accessible to tour
groups people from the public who come
through here is Republican Congressman
Daryl Issa appearing on Fox News and he
is directly bringing up the hunter Biden
thing he straight up says listen uh
Hunter Biden that's someone with a
history of drug addiction they find
cocaine there
I don't know I don't know here he is by
the way there's no evidence that this
has anything to do with Hunter Biden
it's actually quite stupid to think it
does let's listen huge difference uh
when in fact all the president and then
before that vice president had to do was
make it appear as though he was behind
his son he has done that before he did
it yesterday he continues to have
somebody with a history of drug
addiction uh in the white house uh and
uh it is not a small problem that we
find cocaine after Hunter Biden's been
in the White House and people rolled
their eyes and say you know we never had
this before how could what's changed
yeah right interestingly we didn't have
it under Obama
we didn't have it under George W bush
that that we knew about but Daryl Issa
is being so irresponsible here now
obviously this is another one of these
completely ridiculous narratives that
accomplishes nothing as Republicans
continue to offer absolutely nothing by
way of policy to the American people
that shouldn't be ignored specifics
aside just the fact that this is what
they're talking about
I I just to do it justice I'm not
finding any information that Hunter
Biden is is using cocaine at this point
in time uh the cocaine was found where
visitors leave their belongings
so there's really no particular reason
to say hunter Biden has anything to do
with this whatsoever and at some point
you would think let me apply a little
bit of logic here if Biden's son were
using cocaine and if he were using it at
the White House these are all claims for
which we have no evidence if all of
those things were true
why would he be doing it in the area
where visitors leave their belongings in
fact he would almost certainly not be
there the fact that this is where it was
found is essentially a guarantee this
has nothing to do with Hunter Biden but
you know they they don't they didn't do
their health care plan they didn't build
the wall they didn't solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict they didn't
do any of those things so what they've
got is Biden's son is in the White House
and he's snorting lines of coke while he
is there one of our sponsors today is
replace your mortgage mortgages are a
really interesting thing in the United
States the poor often can't afford them
and the rich often don't use them
instead the wealthy use special
Financial tools to pay off their debts
often in a fraction of the time that it
takes for a middle-class American to
realize that same payoff replace your
mortgage teaches you how you can pay off
your home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your university.com slash Pacman
to watch the interview I did with their
founder Michael Lush to learn how you
can get exclusive access to what can be
a life-changing virtual event the link
is in the description